[Music]
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
this morning we introduce you to a
world-class chess player bringing his
knowledge of the game
to under-served communities around st
louis
when he was 12 years old justice
williams was the youngest ever
african-american national chess master
now more than a decade later nancy chen
shows us
how he's how he's inspiring the next
generation
to think like a grand master is really
not that hard which pawn gets to the
other side of the board first
remember our goal is to think 10 moves
ahead when the lesson of the day is to
think
10 moves ahead each decision whether by
pawn or by queen has consequences
in this st louis neighborhood
23-year-old justice williams
spends his saturday mornings teaching
the centuries-old game
to a new generation of chess players
what's your favorite part about playing
chess i like to win a lot
and i hear you win quite a bit you beat
your dad
and a lot of other pronouns their
teacher
ranked among the top 1 percent of
players in the country
in 2010 as a 12-year-old williams became
the youngest
african-american national chess master
if you have a bishop it always stays on
its covers
partnering with a local non-profit
williams started the program last fall
to make chess more accessible for black
youth in the st louis area
its name black squares what is the
meaning behind black squares
to play a legal game of chess white
moves first and often that means that
players think that white has the
advantage but i find my own advantages
with black
advantages williams honed after joining
the chess club at his new york city
elementary school
you had a tough start in chess oh i had
an awful start like i used to go to
tournaments i would lose all my games
so you had never played chess before
that no did anyone in your family play
chess
no they didn't play together and nobody
definitely played with me
but william's real expertise came from
some unlikely
teachers i traveled from the bronx to
washington square park
um on the train by subway by myself i
would play those guys there
but i think that that time playing blitz
in the park really set me apart because
i was
dealing with adults and adult trash talk
the practice paid off williams spent his
teens traveling the world for
competitions
seventh place was justice williams
he was even featured in a documentary on
a junior high chess team
the game earning him a full college
scholarship in st
louis in life there's a lot of judgment
calls
and in chess you got to make a lot of
decisions so we're learning here just
how to analyze and interpret situations
and that's how you not only become not
the problem but also the solution
there's a lot of options out here it's
just what you choose to occupy your idle
time
that mission has led williams to open a
new world of queens and kings
to underserved communities of all kinds
of all this y'all gonna have to play
this man right here more than a hundred
inmates at the st louis county justice
center compete in chess tournaments
organized by williams i played some of
my cousins
who were previously incarcerated we
developed like a different kind of bond
from playing chess
and then talking to some of the players
in the park some of them are
incarcerated
and that's where they learn how to play
the game he picked up on a whim
as an eight-year-old becoming his life's
strategy
when i play chess i'm looking for what
my opponent is not looking for
the communities that we're targeting
we're targeting them because
nobody else is targeting them right
we're looking for the
solution that nobody else is looking for
a sign that despite his lesson for the
day
williams is thinking well more than 10
moves ahead
for cbs this morning nancy chen saint
louis
boy i like what he said life is a series
of judgment calls right justice
bravo yes makes me want to learn how to
play